un jour j'ai eu un déclic de me dire que
cette poche qui étaient là sur mon
ventre elle me sauver la vie de tous les
jours et qu'il fallait que j'apprenne
elle aimait tout simplement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fait ce que je vois est ce que je
mange je l'absorbent pas c'est à dire
que dès que je bois un verre d'eau bafé
ressort dans la poche dès que je mange
ça repart dans la poche
donc je suis hyper face je mange comme
trois garçons réunis et je bois beaucoup
pour compenser justement ce manque
on
je fais pipi ma vessie fonctionne très
bien et ce qui sort de la poche c'est
pas du cas car en fait c'est de l'eau
tout simplement parce que le colon c'est
l'organe qui a pour rôle de solidifier
les selles moi je ne l'est plus du coup
elles n'ont pas le temps d'être
transformés et moi ce qui sort de ma
poche sédogo
[Musique]
je vais voir les pieds oui
c'est de toujours quand elles me
demandent de la prendre en photo de
toujours faire ressortir le positif est
de bien m'être bien mettre en avant est
bon c'est pas difficile parce qu'elle
sourit tout le temps et qu'elle est
toujours rayonnante
parce que c'est là la preuve en photo en
général il en faut pas énormément qui me
fait du bien c'est de voir qu'en france
on est plus de 80000 stomisés et qu'il y
en a énormément qui sont dans l'ombre
comme moi je l'étais au début et
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression d'être le
porte-parole de d'une communauté en
silence
[Musique]
la poche à la phase aller comme ça sur
mon ventre elle est vraiment médicalisé
et nous on en a fait quelque chose de
plus fun
donc voilà les un peu en pilou pour les
enfants mais aussi avec des plumes pour
être plus féminine spécial noël
[Musique]
il est 17 heures et je m'apprête à me
perfusé je suis en pyjama parce qu'après
du coup je peux plus me changer une fois
plus perfusé donc c'est parti je
m'habille un petit je trouve mon corps
absorbe que 20 % de ce que je pense
qu'il n'est pas suffisant pour me
nourrir et m'hydrater correctement et la
perfusion elle est vraiment nécessaire
pour que je manque de rien et que je
n'ai aucune carence pour 15h00 j'ai
besoin de 2,5 litres 5k d'alimentation
et d'hydratation afin de nourrir
hydrater correctement au début j'avais
une infirmière à domicile qui venait
trois fois par semaine pour me faire les
soins et après j'ai décidé de faire un
stage pour mme autonomiser fermé soin de
tout seul aujourd'hui je gère tout seul
donc je me perds fusent sur mon cas des
terres centrales à la poitrine le sens
vers 17 heures jusqu'à 9 heures le
lendemain matin quand je suis perfusé
j'arrive quand même à à bouger à marcher
de la chambre pour ça donc là on va
cuisiner parce que j'ai faim apéro je
vis de ma poche plus de 50 fois par jour
parce que ba tour au sort immédiatement
dans la poche tout ce que j'adore tout
ce que jamal ressort dans la poche
je peux pas travailler parce que ben 15
heures sur 24 ça laisse peu de liberté
et je suis très vite fatigué
à l'âge de 13 ans j'ai été diagnostiqué
d'une rectocolite hémorragique
c'est une maladie intestinale chronique
donc de 13 à 19 ans j'ai essayé tout
plein de traitements qu'ils n'ont pas
fonctionné à 18 ans j'ai recourir à la
chirurgie qui s'est mal passé donc le
chercher à couper à mauvaise artères pu
malgré tout ça j'arrive à assortir à
voir mes amis a essayé d'organiser à
plein de petites sorties sympas voile
avec d'organisation encore une fois tout
est possible
[Musique]